[Music]
have you guys in your quarantine time
learned any new skills skills skills
have you guys figured out anything about
yourself through partners I'll be
picking lemons but I don't have partners
what imaginary partners I have a lemon
partner what's your learning partner uh
haven't really named that I already ate
her so are you later I just hate her
not hearing it's gone yeah well we'll be
in quarantine with your partners have
you guys learned anything specifically
about them that you don't like you like
yeah I found out she's a Crumpler a what
really like know when you you know when
you poop there are folders and couplers
yeah she's a crumb I never even knew
crumbles big that's a big portion of the
population I found out I thought that
stopped at six years old no a lot of
people people won't let you go see messy
and weight control and and touch you
anywhere I'm all the ways they can go
deeper because now it's 3d I don't know
I know multiple people were crumpled and
I brought that up to somebody else I'm
like you know you're carpals and he's
like yeah me too and I'm like how does
that work yeah I do because I was just
thinking it's like Jordan is the
definition of crumpled is it explained
how does this work yeah I don't know
other paper oh wait no you're gonna wipe
your butt so do that there's a burr I'm
crumpled no no you hold it you hold it
where it doesn't uncouple what okay wait
are you doing a two-finger huh you just
do this so your finger like slides along
on the paper expands as soon as you take
it off your booty boy it kind of drop it
this is what I do
oh that's a different technique that's a
wastrel why are you wasting this side
yeah now take it out
that's what would your hand back on top
like a glove
why did you keep it out of it yeah cuz
then you could use your fingers like
this that's a wonderful waste the part
is not I Tessa both out crumpling but
you could definitely even fold it and
use it again that's another thing do you
reuse so many times I try to save it as
my toilet paper you can [ __ ] to use
that [ __ ] how how do you uncouple in
couple different ways but you can do it
it what you know so you wipe it wads
right you wipe it once and then you just
fold over where the poo is Andy from
your wife I have to take it out you
don't look at your [ __ ] no why do you
know when you're going to clean I know
wipe what do you mean okay when you
white I to know that you're at least a
cover on the [ __ ] going forward and
you know it's the last time if you don't
look at all like smooth the wipes oh oh
because there's more friction like it's
dry yeah residual you know you look at
it but I have to go three times three
different rolls of toilet paper
whole rolls that's stupid and then I go
then I can check also are you under over
over over I can't do under why Dickson
the way damn you got some say people all
guys right unless you're a child and
said right
[Laughter]
well I bring this up because I also have
a list of 30 unusual things that are
things people learn about the partners
that they don't like everything
I can only be learning a new active
during this warn you never was like
booop you've never seen but you know
more about bars and you know the same
amount about Bart that I do we still get
surprised here what I want to know I
want to know what are these things so
this one there's different categories so
one is unusual eating strategies so a
lady wrote it's a thing I learned about
my partner in these quarantine e times
he eats the last slice of pizza from the
crust to tip I repeat serial killer run
Lanie run you like there are certain
things that we do for fun as a child
that becomes ritual true like it with
hamburgers that makes sense that the the
pizza thing is so hamburgers I like to
eat around the hamburgers and then eat
the middle part the last cuz it's the
[ __ ] best bite is the juiciest by the
tomatoes in the middle the pickles in
the middle the onion the lead is to
catch up everything's in the middle you
rotated this way peeling in shape you
know what there was meat that would hang
off of the bun I'm not eating that [ __ ]
what it was just weird but it was just
so weird cuz I'm like it's not contained
ill I like to so you got all OCD with
the burger that's I couldn't have
Wendy's because it was a square and I'm
like no you like shave off the core
square and it's funny how when these
claims are the most like natural they
don't freeze it but they still make
their burgers and squares the whole
sheet in the cut into squares yeah what
is natural habitat of the hamburger okay
say you got how would you form a square
easier than a circle oh you you spread
out and then cut into squares yeah it's
the same way you make a circle huh we
just wrap it and you squeeze then you
put it down you squish it that's not
natural though natural is just say it
occurs naturally in nature come on
Mackey say it would be a loose meat no
you'd be a cow shape it would just be
like yeah to be in the cow
that's natural is just so this guy Sileo
by his girlfriend so he's like who says
you can't put isolation time to good use
I for instance just learned my
girlfriend's middle name
what how many how many months something
weeks even have you guys seen that few
words like shout out to all the ladies
who are in new relationships they're in
day 21 a quarantine and pretending that
they don't [ __ ] oh yeah that's gotta be
a nightmare you know which it would be
one nightmare if like if we were on
super quarantine and they were really
enforcing it and you had a one-night
stand or something now you're stuck with
that person and it's like my law you're
stuck with them well it's a good movie
idea you're welcome because it's
probably like I hate you first and then
they're gonna follow those yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's open to a lot of [ __ ]
so the next one what absolutely horrific
thing have you learned it by your spouse
slash partner during quarantine I
learned that mine pronounces rhesus the
candy like Reese's Reese's pcs that's
not a part see what is it well how do
you say it really just even know just
one that when it's really like this
moment that's not that bad boon he said
out loud it's like Reese's who the [ __ ]
says it as like Reese's Reese's or you
say Reese's I said Reese's Isis Reese's
Pieces Reese's Pieces yeah I think
personally for so long cuz we change our
arse at the W's I would have never
caught it until he said it here and like
we you call it wally bully so you
thought he was doing bear talk with you
yeah cuz we changed all ours
oh god yeah but he just said wooly so
when he when he says it with me I just
think he's been cute but then he
mentioned it here where he's not trying
to be cute and he said wooly Poli and
I'm like you say wooly Poli yeah isn't
it Momo P what's funny cuz Rolie polies
already the cute it is key
what is that call we just called Roly
Polys that's not a scientific name
crustacean right position I figured
right it's like I said to pee but I just
don't really like because it has like a
hard shell like you belong into that
specification [ __ ] off I think so I
think we're stations going oh [ __ ] yeah
I know I get that you know cuz a loss
sir but I'm just saying like I think
I've read it somewhere we're like really
employees could be like for our
descendants that yeah all day detect
with the exoskeletons and [ __ ] right
I'll eat the [ __ ] out of a shrimp but I
don't know about a roly-poly though hmm
no what are the fried Oh yep
why the tree in Thailand I like the the
markets the sumac there's my a spider
before I know it's so small there's no
point in eating it oh I feel like this
so small you don't have that much like
juice and stuff inside they're more
crunchy like grasshoppers I rather eat
sunflower seeds yeah that's a good idea
alright so since we're together 24/7 now
every day I get to learn something new
about my partner today I learned that
he's kind of a [ __ ] that doesn't
replace the toilet paper once it rolls
out sometimes I'm like I really want to
get back to my game or I really want to
get back to the movies take that long
yeah you get used to it
yeah I feel like I need to stop because
when I am in a relationship or have
someone living with me yeah that's
annoying I forget how do you guys refill
it like is that is the toilet paper a
right way now over/under yeah but I do
believe it should be on the outside but
when you do on the inside where it falls
under be able to grapple with one arm
and like pull it off better than you can
with the other we have to stop it oh you
could just go what like the way you
would
the table you just have to whip your
[ __ ] well that one you kind of hold
with your wrist you do the same thing
with Oliver with your guess - no but
this one's harder it's like I'm with you
on that
yeah so you prefer under than over it
makes a movie more sense
make sure it's Massa don't you try that
doesn't even put it back sometimes you
don't even you start sewing all right
hate when they [ __ ] uh-uh I forgot to
me it's like it's like they don't
replace the toilet paper it's kinda like
if people won't take out the trash you
know where like the trash that's awesome
oh yeah I'm like no why are you laying
it my roommates are so [ __ ] bad with
that their guys at the normal roommate
like problem kind of it doesn't smell
but like you open in your like you kid
because we have one that goes inside the
under that what do you call the jar you
have to pull it out and it's like kind
of like stuck like oh no things are
falling I would eat it on your life to
pick it up that is pretty bad well what
is the last piece that's like what's the
last one that goes on top we have you
what Oh like on the trash yeah I saved
that if there's a lid if it touches the
lid and then if it doesn't have a lady
from us that goes over the barrier yeah
I try to max it out because a trash bag
reason well they stopped it right if
you're if it touches the top push it
down I'm not trying to be wasteful I
just thought of one that part does not
that I learned in the quarantine but it
pisses me the [ __ ] off it hasn't changed
it yeah this [ __ ] will like
either drink something or eat something
and there's like a little bit left like
not even half of a serving left for a
person not even type the size serving
left and he puts it right back in the
fridge wherever yeah so he could drink
it later no he's done for him
not because he like counts as calories
and he only goes per serving oh you saw
it oh I think that says Asian and I ate
it and Mike like when you eat like
family smell and like especially Chinese
food I get I can only speak from a
Chinese perspective but like if there's
like one more piece of meat or one more
piece of veggie in the middle but I
usually don't want to take the last one
I don't know why that's a courtesy thing
in Chinese culture so why doesn't you
just throw it away because he's an
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]